Ross I realize we just briefly touched
on this but what is then the art of
creating hit web content I mean how much
of it can be orchestrated you know in
the let's take the you know Freddie Wong
and Brandon Laatsch with video game high
school how much of it is a combination
of chance timing creativity I think it
is serendipity I certainly think there
are skills to making a good web series
to having a good story having compelling
characters even nuts-and-bolts things
like hey have some decent sound and not
bad sound all those things I think are
are important but I I think if you could
put a formula together Sony and
everybody else in the big media world
would have done that and they can't do
it they can't do it with 200 million
dollar movies they certainly can't do it
with web series so I you know again I
think you have to start with something
that you find entertaining yourself and
then I think you need to make sure that
you're taking care with each step of the
process that you don't just get an idea
and grab your camera and rush out to
start filming something that you plan
out who the characters are how will they
work together what is the general arc of
your series going to be take time
writing the pilot script I have a lot of
students who will they'll pitch me the
story for the pilot script and I say
well not much is happening and they say
well really cool stuff happens in
episode 3 and my response is always well
no one's gonna stick around and watch
episode 3 unless really cool stuff
happens in episode 1 and so you know
you've really got to grab the audience
and we've got the audience now on a web
series has there trigger finger on the
mouse button from the beginning and and
they're they're almost physically
predisposed to clicking their their
index finger every 5 seconds so you've
really got to grab their attention but
you know you do your best work
you make sure that you're getting real
actors to to play the parts that you've
got good sound that you've thought out
what you want the visual look of the
series to be that you really make it as
good as you can
even the beginning and end credits I
think one of the great examples from a
fee for the feature film world of how
you use every second is the movie long
time ago airplane and it was a broad
comedy but they had comedy right to the
very last credit of the movie the last
credit they would put things in the
credit like best boy which is an
assistant to one of the lighting people
and they would put the actual name of
the best boy in the movie but then the
next credit would be worst boy Adolf
Hitler and and they would just put in
things like A Tale of Two Cities written
by Charles Dickens and so the credits
became entertaining right up to the
boiler plate legal thing at the end that
says this film may not be duplicated
without violating penal code 1.3 to 575
so there and I thought that's just
brilliant
they made the the most boring thing you
can imagine required legal warning into
a joke in the film so you know I think
that's a great example of how you do
your best give it your all in every
aspect of the webseries you're putting
together well it almost sounds like
creating a viral video is similar to
choosing a stock and and and there's
real you know you could look at all the
financials you could see who the CEO was
in their prior performance and you still
don't know if this thing's gonna you
know your pass it's moving day average
or whatever so what are some of the
things that you've seen people do once
they see that their thing has not gone
viral do they abandon it do they keep
working at it oh I would hope that they
that they keep working whether they do
the same thing over and over again is
may not be the wisest thing to do but
write your next piece right you know you
I think creating series and writing in
general you get better at it with
practice there and you know a lot of
people who are writing web series are
fairly early in their learning curve of
being writers or filmmakers and I really
would advise them to move on to the next
project it's it sometimes it's tempting
for young artists to feel that their
idea is so precious that this is the one
and only idea that's great and I think
you need to get past that and say okay
tried it out good learning experience
now I know how to do it better
next time I mean I've been writing
professionally for over 30 years now I'm
still learning every time I write a
piece I once wrote a novelist who said
every every novel you write is your
first novel because you haven't written
that novel before and so you'd have to
put the time you in learning and you'll
get better so what is the sort of the
timeframe to try something out where
they're not because I've seen a lot of
these sort of serial creative types
where they come up with this great
precious idea and then somehow they
abandon it and there's various reasons
why yeah there's a real tension between
you know you don't want to just get an
idea and rush out and shoot it tomorrow
and and not put any planning into into
it but there you can also get caught in
the I'm going to write my 900th draft of
this script trap or I'm gonna do one
more edit and so on so you have to find
a balance between being thoughtful and
being careful and doing your best work
and just trying to reach something
that's unattainable which is perfection
I get another example I give my students
of the kind of care that professionals
put into their work it is I have a copy
of an outline from the series Mad Men
it's from the fourth season it's the
first episode of the fourth season it's
written by the show's creator so he's
done the show for three years he's won
Emmys for Outstanding Drama three years
in a row at that point in time clearly
knows the show and his craft very well
at the top of the outline it says tenth
draft so that's a professional and puts
that kind of care effort and revision
into his work so again it's a balance
you don't want it to say 150 F that
seems too many to me how many times do
you have to rein your students in and
say okay guys realize this is a grand
idea but you know this isn't you don't
have James Cameron behind it so you've
got to do more of a tape type of thing
where it's just one room what you know
yeah well they you know they they have a
limitation the the budget for starters
but there are all kinds of ways that
that's your job as a professor and as
someone who's been a professional to try
to give them your perspective sometimes
they'll be pitching the story idea to me
I'll just say you can't do that in five
minutes that's you've just pitched
eleven scenes each of which is
approximately a minute and a half and
that I need to give them that
perspective I make them when they're
preparing to go shoot not only create a
shot list but create something I call a
time management budget where they cut
and paste their shot list and say okay
our call time on Saturday is 8 a.m.
between 8 a.m. and 11 a.m. we're gonna
do these shots here and there in the
list and you can see real quickly when
you say really but so let's not say
11:00 a.m. let's say 8:00 and 9:00 a.m.
you're gonna do 21 setups between 8 & 9
a.m. I don't think so that that's not
right or I just had this conversation
yesterday with the students where I said
I think you've got something pretty
ambitious here and your project what you
with your pilot they were shooting
episodes now subsequent episodes you
found that improv with the actors work
really well so you want to make sure you
leave time for that and they had a
response to this which is well we think
we're gonna go faster because we have
two cameras and we've got an extra hour
and a half at the end of the day that's
kind of fudge time that week if we spill
over into it that's okay
so you know that's part of the dialogue
do you engage in as a professor with the
students to make sure that they're
benefiting from your experience
you